not leaving because of sex even because  of financial reasons that we said so  it's not about I don't I mean secretary  did you know one of the number one  indicators of divorce is the woman out  earning the man  I can see that yeah but it goes back to  because the woman one of the reasons is  because the woman is around all these  men that she wants but no but then if if  we're talking about is it is it sex or  is it money because if it's if she's if  she's leaving because he's not earned  enough that's different than this no  that's selfish but that's it's about  being a selfish woman that is selfish if  you're leaving and breaking up a home  because he's not earning enough money  that's selfish it's okay to want that  but if you if you sign the papers if you  got married to him and now you think  you're above him because you make more